In the previous unit, we've worried about two object references that pointed to
different objects. Now we're going to look at a different situation, when
object reference doesn't point anywhere at all. Let me explain that. Over here,
you have a situation with which you are very familiar. We have a variable that
references an object,
[INAUDIBLE]
cat. Now, my favorite cat is in fact my cat, Eliza. But maybe Sarah doesn't
like cats and her favorite wouldn't be any cat at all. That is in the variable
her favorite, there wouldn't be any reference to any cat object. In Java, she
denote such a reference to no object at all with the keyword null. So this
variable here holds this special null reference. This variable here holds a
reference to some cat object. Generally, you would use this distinction meaning
either a reference to a specific object or a null reference if the object is
optional to test whether a variable is null or not. You use equal, equal and
you test, is this reference the null reference? Now, if there is a chance that
a object contains null. It actually is important that you make that test.
Because if you invoke a method on a null reference, then something bad happens
and the method called blows up. Well, it doesn't really blow up, of course. But
it does terminate your program with a null pointer exception. It is simply
illegal to call any method on null, don't do it. Instead, make this test first.
I've prepared a little quiz here, where I'm going to ask you about several
kinds of tests. So here's the situation, our intrepid reporter went to city
hall to get a statement from the mayor. And now I'd like you to give me the
java code to test whether the statement was one of the following. Did the mayor
say no comment? Just type in here, what you would put inside the parentheses of
an if statement to check for that a couple more. Did the mayor say nothing at
all? And finally, did the reporter not manage to get a statement? Maybe he was
stuck in traffic. So, just type in the conditions for each one of them.